Bonjour tout le monde
et bienvenue dans ce nouveau podcast
dans beaucoup de mes vidéos
je parle de l'immersion
je dis que pour apprendre une langue
c'est important pardon de faire de l'immersion
de regarder du contenu
de lire des livres dans la langue que l'on apprend
de faire de l'écoute etc ...
l'immersion c'est la clé pour avoir plus de vocabulaire
pour s'approprier
la langue pour apprendre une langue
c'est en général ce qu'on
présente comme un apprentissage plus naturel
d'un côté on a un apprentissage assez théorique
avec toutes les règles de grammaire par exemple
et de l'autre on va avoir un apprentissage plus naturel
avec l'immersion
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui est très
commun dans l'apprentissage des langues
et si vous regardez des vidéos sur YouTube
souvent les personnes expliquent que l'immersion
c'est très important
pour apprendre une langue
en général il faut voilà
regarder une vidéo
écouter un podcast
ou lire quelque chose dans la langue que l'on apprend
un peu tous les jours
si jamais j'ai quelques notes
pour cette vidéo donc
ne soyez pas surpris si je regarde
vers le bas
si je regarde en bas à droite
mais du coup on a cette idée de l'immersion
de l'apprentissage naturel qui est de regarder
le plus possible
d'écouter le plus possible la langue que l'on apprend
et en fait aujourd'hui j'avais envie de parler
plus précisément de l'immersion
tout simplement
parce qu'il y a plusieurs sortes d'immersion
il y a ce qu'on appelle l'immersion intensive
et l'immersion extensive
donc pour commencer avec l'immersion intensive
je pense que c'est l'idée la plus commune
qu'on se fait de l'immersion
c'est quand on pense à l'immersion
on s'imagine surtout l'immersion intensive
qu'est-ce que c'est l'immersion intensive c'est
regarder un contenu
et essayer d'apprendre un maximum de vocabulaire
en général on dit qu'il faut
il faut avoir une compréhension
qui soit assez bonne mais pas parfaite
du contenu qu'on va regarder
pour que cette immersion intensive soit efficace
l'idée c'est d'avoir une compréhension
de déjà connaître environ 70% des mots jusqu'à 90%
le contenu doit être
ne doit pas être pardon trop difficile
et il ne doit pas être trop facile
si vous regardez quelque chose de trop facile
vous n'allez pas apprendre
de nouveaux mots de vocabulaire
si vous regardez quelque chose de trop difficile
vous n'allez rien comprendre et ça va être inefficace
et du coup
cette immersion intensive
c'est l'idéal
c'est d'avoir un contenu où on connaît 70% de mots ou
entre 70 et 90% des mots
pour pouvoir apprendre le maximum de nouveaux mots
cette immersion
intensive elle vise à élargir au maximum
son vocabulaire dans la langue
c'est fait pour apprendre
le maximum de mots de vocabulaire
ou même de structure grammaticale
de règles de grammaire
de structures de phrase nouvelles
comme c'est difficile
il faut être concentré
pour essayer d'apprendre ces nouveaux mots
ces nouvelles règles de grammaire
pour pouvoir apprendre le plus possible
et ça c'est je pense que c'est l'immersion
entre guillemets classiques
parce que quand on pense à l'immersion dans une langue
on s'imagine voilà qu'il faut faire une pratique
dans laquelle on apprend tous les jours
et du coup quand le contenu devient trop facile
il faut changer et il faut passer à un contenu
plus difficile
c'est quelque chose que j'ai fait avec le japonais
il y a une chaîne YouTube
notamment de podcast en japonais
qui s'appelle
Bite size japanese
et en fait au bout d'un moment
quand je commençais à regarder une vidéo
de cette chaîne
je me rendais compte que je comprenais tout facilement
si je regarde mon application
vous voyez qu'en fait en haut
j'ai le nombre de mots que je connais en japonais
donc là techniquement
il me dit que je connais
4500 mots de japonais
et en fait cette application ce qui est pratique
c'est que quand je lance une vidéo sur mon ordinateur
l'application me dit
quel pourcentage de mots je connais
dans cette vidéo
donc ça c'est idéal pour l'immersion
parce que on sait si c'est trop difficile
ou si c'est trop facile
et du coup au bout d'un moment
les vidéos de cette chaîne YouTube Bite size japanese
ben j'avais des taux
j'avais des pourcentages
qui était de 95 98% de mots que je connaissais déjà
et du coup
je pouvais regarder une vidéo entière
et ne pas comprendre juste 2 ou 3 mots
donc ce que j'ai fait c'est qu'au bout d'un moment
j'ai arrêté de regarder ces vidéos
pour me concentrer sur un contenu plus difficile
qui me permet
qui puisse me permettre
d'apprendre beaucoup plus de vocabulaire
et plus de règles de grammaire
et donc ça c'est la démarche classique
entre guillemets pardon
que j'ai eu avec le japonais
mais le problème de cette immersion intensive
c'est que
au bout d'un moment
ça peut devenir fatiguant
c'est-à-dire que tous les jours
il faut être concentré sur un contenu
essayez vraiment d'apprendre le maximum
voir voilà le nombre de mots que je connais
je voulais voir ce chiffre augmenter
le plus rapidement possible
pour penser
avoir une bonne connaissance de la langue pour que ma
connaissance de la langue
soit meilleur
le plus rapidement possible
donc ça c'est quelque chose d'assez fatiguant
parce que ça demande beaucoup de concentration
et ensuite
cette immersion
elle ne nous permet pas de parler la langue
ça c'est un problème assez commun c'est
j'arrive à comprendre mais je n'arrive pas à parler
et ça j'en ai fait l'expérience au Japon puisque
je connaissais déjà beaucoup de mots de vocabulaire
j'avais utilisé une application
qui s'appelle Wani Kani et qui permet
d'apprendre les caractères japonais
et je crois que j'avais dû apprendre
2000 caractères ou
peut-être 1500 caractères
avant d'aller au Japon
et pourtant quand je suis arrivé
je n'arrivais pas à parler
j'arrivais à comprendre mais je n'arrivais pas à parler
donc cette immersion
elle n'est pas utile
pour apprendre à parler
ce qui est d'un côté logique
mais on va voir que il y a d'autres façons de faire
et du coup au début
j'avais beaucoup de mal à parler
comme j'étais au Japon
comme on est allé travailler dans des fermes au Japon
on a eu de plus en plus l'opportunité de parler
et là au fur et à mesure
j'ai commencé à arriver à parler
en japonais
et en fait je me suis rendu compte d'une chose
c'est que
au fur et à mesure que j'ai commencé à pouvoir parler
que tout ça s'est débloqué
ben au fur et à mesure
j'ai commencé à avoir des automatismes en japonais
c'est-à-dire que je pouvais dire des phrases
sans réfléchir
ça c'est un problème qui est assez commun
c'était le cas au début en japonais
c'est le cas aussi de certains de mes élèves
c'est que quand ils essaient de parler
ils réfléchissent
ils essaient de construire
toute la phrase dans leur tête
avant de la dire et du coup
ça fait que ce n'est pas très fluide
la discussion est très ralentie
parce que
les personnes prennent beaucoup de temps à réfléchir
et du coup au début moi en japonais c'était ça
mais petit à petit j'ai vu des automatismes se former
c'est-à-dire pouvoir dire une phrase
sans même réfléchir juste parce que ça vient comme ça
comme dans notre langue maternelle finalement
et ça en fait
j'ai réalisé au bout d'un moment
que ces phrases que je disais
automatiquement
sans réfléchir
c'est grâce à l'immersion extensive
donc on parlait de l'immersion intensive
qui vise à avoir de plus en plus de vocabulaire
à apprendre le maximum de choses
l'immersion extensive
c'est l'inverse
c'est-à-dire qu'on va regarder du contenu facile
on va regarder un maximum de contenu facile
et en fait je me suis rendu compte
que tous les automatismes que j'avais dans la langue
ça venait surtout
des vidéos de cette chaîne Bite size japanese
comme je comprenais tout facilement
je pouvais regarder une vidéo entière sans mettre pause
et comme je comprenais
c'était intéressant à regarder
c'était amusant
ce n'était pas difficile
et du coup je
j'écoutais entièrement ce que disait la personne
et ça en fait
ça m'a permis de créer des automatismes
grâce à la manière dont s'exprime la personne
comme elle dit des phrases
elle dit un peu toujours les mêmes phrases
dans les vidéos
ça permet de créer des automatismes
et récemment en fait
j'ai recommencé à regarder ses vidéos
et en même temps je me suis intéressé
à la l'immersion extensive
en général on parle d'extensive reading
mais ça s'applique aussi au listening
à au contenu vidéo etc
et je suis tombé sur une vidéo du YouTubeur Lucas
Lampariello qui je pense est italien
et il me semble qu'il est polyglotte donc
il parle plusieurs langues
de manière fluent
et il dit une phrase qui est
extensive immersion is the road to fluency
il dit cette phrase parce que l'immersion extensive
a des bénéfices
a des effets positifs qui permettent
de favoriser l'expression dans la langue
si je vous liste ces bénéfices
on a bah déjà c'est facile à regarder
à lire ou à écouter
c'est amusant
et on peut en regarder beaucoup de ce contenu
tout simplement parce que ça ne demande aucun effort
si vous regardez cette vidéo
et que ça ne vous demande aucun effort
vous pouvez la regarder du début à la fin
sans mettre pause
sans essayer de comprendre un mot que vous ne
connaissiez pas
etc donc c'est facile à regarder
on peut en regarder beaucoup
c'est motivant
parce que
on comprend du contenu dans la langue que l'on apprend
quand je regarde
les vidéos de Bite size japanese
j'ai l'impression d'être fluent en japonais
tout simplement parce que je comprends quasi
quasiment tout
alors que quand je regarde
une vidéo ou une série
qui est beaucoup plus difficile à comprendre
j'ai l'impression d'être complètement nul
donc finalement
ces contenus faciles permettent de d'avoir
une bonne estime
on va dire de notre niveau dans la langue
on a l'impression
d'être fort dans la langue et c'est motivant
du coup on peut en regarder une grande quantité
avec beaucoup de répétitions
plus vous regardez en quantité du contenu
plus vous allez avoir de répétition
sur les phrases utilisées
quand on dit apprendre du vocabulaire
on parle souvent de système SRS
qui sont des
logiciels qui permettent d'avoir des cartes
qui soient revues régulièrement
c'est-à-dire que tous les jours
on a les cartes qui reviennent
et grâce à cette répétition
on mémorise plus facilement
et bien en fait là c'est pareil
avec la quantité de contenu qu'on va regarder
comme bite size Japanese par exemple
elle sort 2 ou 3 vidéos par semaine
et comme ça me demande aucun effort à regarder
je peux regarder toutes ces vidéos
et en fait
2 à 3 fois par semaine j'ai 20minutes de podcast
que je comprends facilement
et du coup ça crée beaucoup de répétitions
puisque elle s'exprime
toujours un peu de la même manière
ce qui est naturel
et du coup cette répétition
permet de
d'apprendre
plus automatiquement
le vocabulaire
s'installe naturellement
comme on voit toujours à peu près les mêmes mots
ça devient de plus en plus naturel
et également comme tout est facile
dès qu'il y a un mot qu'on ne comprend pas
on peut le deviner facilement et on apprend à deviner
d'après le contexte
de nouveaux mots de vocabulaire
quand on est dans un contenu assez difficile
il faut aller chercher dans le dictionnaire
pour être sûr
du sens de la phrase
au global
quand vous avez une compréhension de 95% d'une vidéo
les 5% les quelques mots que vous ne comprenez pas
vous pouvez les déduire
du contexte global
et ça c'est une très bonne pratique
et finalement grâce à cette répétition
à cette facilité
on ne se pose moins de questions
sur le sens de ce qu'on écoute
mais on on regarde pleinement enfin on comprend
pleinement ce que ce qu'on regarde
et du coup ça ça va créer des automatismes
le cerveau s'habitue
au son et aux structures de phrases
et ça quand je disais que
au fur à mesure de commencer à parler japonais
j'ai vu des automatismes apparaître
ça venait de ça
parce que je regardais
plusieurs vidéos de cette chaîne YouTube
à chaque fois qu'elle utilisait une expression
pour parler de quelque chose
en particulier
elle le disait de la même manière
et en fait j'ai fini par
imiter cette façon de le dire
et quand on fait comme ça
en fait on ne se pose même plus la question de
ah il faut que je mette un sujet un verbe
ah l'objet ça va être ça non
on le dit juste parce que ça vient comme ça
et ça c'est vraiment quelque chose de bénéfique
à l'extension immersive
parce que
à l'immersion extensive
on n'a pas à se poser d'autres questions
que de juste écouter
et de s'habituer aux formes et aux structures
quand on fait de l'immersion intensive
on se pose beaucoup de questions sur le vocabulaire
la grammaire
donc on cherche vraiment à apprendre des choses
spécifiques quand on fait de l'immersion extensive
on est pleinement en train d'apprendre
en train d'assimiler
des structures naturelles et des formes naturelles
et on a pas de
compteur de mots pour nous dire qu'on progresse
ou que ou qu'on avance dans notre apprentissage
mais ça a vraiment un effet bénéfique sur
notre apprentissage de la langue
et notamment sur l'expression
qu'on va avoir dans la langue
donc c'est en fait le titre de cette vidéo
c'est don't be too harsh with yourself
enfin le titre sur la miniature sûrement
tout simplement parce que à un moment donné
moi je me disais
quand je regardais les vidéos de
Bite size japanese et que je trouvais ça trop facile
je me disais
mais je perds mon temps je n'apprends rien
il faut que je trouve quelque chose de plus difficile
il faut quelque chose où j'apprends beaucoup de mots
de vocabulaire
je vais regarder des articles de journaux
de politique d'économie
et en fait non seulement
ça me décourageait
parce que j'arrivais sur des contenus trop difficiles
et du coup j'avais du mal
à rester concentré
mais en plus du coup ça diminuait mon temps d'immersion
parce que
forcément c'est plus fatiguant
et
ça demande beaucoup plus de concentration
et d'énergie et finalement en fait
j'ai complètement mis de côté cette
immersion extensive
cette immersion facile
alors que c'est quelque chose de très utile
donc l'objectif ici
ce n'est pas de dire
arrêter toute l'immersion
intensive et faites seulement
de l'immersion extensive
c'est plus de dire que les 2 outils sont très efficaces
et il faut équilibrer à un certain moment
pour
pouvoir faire également de l'immersion extensive
qui est une pratique
très bénéfique pour l'apprentissage d'une langue
donc si il y a du contenu facile
que vous aimez regarder
allez-y à fond
le principal c'est la quantité
plus vous écoutez plus ça va créer des automatismes
plus vous aurez de facilité à parler par la suite
donc voilà c'était un peu le message de cette vidéo
c'est de ne pas être trop dans un mode
apprentissage rapide
efficace où il faut apprendre le maximum de mots
mais plus dans une approche vraiment
immersion naturelle
à force d'écouter
à force de regarder des contenus
qui vous plaisent
même s'ils sont très faciles à comprendre
ça va vous aider ça va vous créer des automatismes
dans la langue et ça va vraiment avoir une approche
naturelle de l'apprentissage
de cette langue
donc voilà j'espère que cette vidéo vidéo vous aura plu
n'hésitez pas à essayer
à me faire vos retours dans les commentaires
à mettre un j'aime également si cette vidéo vous a plu
et je vous dis à la prochaine